[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول المؤلف ويحرم البول في الماء الراكد
صلى الله عليه
‏was
to maintain a person
and that
in the
man that they bathed
in the a peninsula at that time there
were no there was not any running there
was not
‏to take anyag
are
takes
يقول
الراكد
يعني الذي لا ينصرف والذي لا يجري الراكد
هو ضد الجاري
[Silence]
small body of that is not flow
‏this isit and againason
[Silence]
نهى ان يبال في الماء الراكد جابرسن
صحيح مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول ويجوز البول قائما والقعود
‏in time
is not for us sitting literally
means sitting on something meaning
youright on
the seat of a toilet
‏is
them that this would come back on a
person's on a person's body even in a
small amount in the form of spatter
when a person relieves himself
‏as
care
if
will
عليه وسلم
was toeved himself both way standing and
however mostly standing
so much
عائشه رضي الله عنها يقول عن حذيفه ان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم انتهى الى سباطه
قوم فبال
قائما سباطه قوم يعني مثل المكان الذي
يلقى فيه المزابل
وهذه الاشياء
ف تنحيت فقال ابنه فدنوت حتى قمت عند
عقبيه
فتوضا ومسح على خفيه هو قال لحذيفه
ادنه يعني الماء يعني تيني بالماء
حذيفه
بخاري
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
urinate
‏place
of all the mention that there was no
angle for him to
himself concealed from the eyes ofers
and
himself in a way that would maintain his
cleanliness third the last thing you
want to
‏is
be close to area that in the desert
right anyone who lives in the desert
knows that snakes and scorpions all hang
out in places that so it becomes
hazardous for a person to put his
body in a position of vulnerability
in a place where trash is discarded
and food and and
‏was other and soat
the propined
himself standing
and the takeaway here from this
narration is that
it is permissible for a person to
relieve himself standing as long as the
person ‏is
safe and maintains his cleanliness
however we know that better
that a person himself sitting
in in any situation unless there is a
need to stand how do we know this
because
tells us inن
من النسائي شيساز
من حدثكم ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
بال قائما فلا تصدقوه ما كان يبول الا
جالسا
هذه تنفي عائشه تنفي حذيفه يثبت
والمثبت
بمثابه
الذي
يزيد في علمي
والمثبت
مقدم على النافي
لان النافي يحدث
بما لا يعلم
يعني هي لا تعلم انه بال جالسا غيرها
يعلم انه بال جالسا فهي زياده علم زياده
ثقه هي مقبوله
عائشه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
always
حذيفه
never
sitting never even of him urinate
sitting
‏standing
what we understand from this we
understand that
the exceptional
maority of time and instances he would
always be so much so that could even him
standing
however
‏science which is
exercise logic and understanding and
harmonizing
a person who
narrates
something in the positive
takes precedence over someone whoates a
negative
so someone comes and say whoever says
this happened don't believe
‏some
take
[Silence]
harmonizing both we see that very rarely
would he himself standing
[Silence]
‏ion
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان
ينفعنا بما علمنا والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد